تتمثل الخطة في محاولة إطلاق هذا قبل
الصيف
للمساعدة في السفر الأوروبي الآمن الآن
موجة ثالثة من أوروبا التي تجتاح أوروبا
تبدو مثل اليونان والبرتغال
التي تعتمد اقتصاداتها
بشكل كبير على السياحة ، من الواضح أنك تريد الحصول على
جواز سفر اللقاح هذا
لأشهر الصيف.  أنت
ترى
أي معارضة من الدول الأعضاء الأخرى في
هذه المرحلة ،
لا ، لدينا دعم حقيقي من
الدول الأعضاء وحتى الآن ،
ذهب مفتوح من البرلمان المفتوح هذا
الصباح إلى البرلمان الأوروبي
لشرح
ما نحاول القيام به في الواقع نحن
نفكر  عن الصيف المقبل كما قلت
، لذا نريد أن نكون مستعدين بلائحة جديدة ،
لذا فإن
القانون يفرض ضمان نفس
الشهادة
في جميع الدول الأعضاء في أوروبا
ويكون الاستعداد أو ما شابه ذلك هو حل تقني
حل رقمي
لكن يجب أن يكون من الممكن لجميع
المواطنين أن يطلبوا شهادة على ورق
أو شهادة رقمية ولكن هو
إعادة الاتصال بالعالم أه من
الخادم بالطبع نحاول أن نكون مستعدين
لذلك  تسهيل الحركة الحرة في
أوروبا منذ بداية شهر
يوليو ونحاول نفس الشيء مع الأشخاص
القادمين من بلدان ثالثة